my name is Michael Novak I'm 34 years
old and I'm a dancer with the Paul
Taylor Dance Company in New York City I
have what I call the recipe which is
something that I've built over a number
of years of dancing the first is a cross
training program and that can involve
weight lifting gyro tonics yoga some
kind of aerobic activity like swimming
in the pool cardio the second part is
getting ready for the rehearsals and
that can range from taking daily
technique classes which can be ballet or
modern going over all the dances that I
have to do and in a given day which can
range from one dance to six or seven
dances the third one is performances so
a performance day is a bit different
because we have what's called a tech
rehearsal where we basically run the
entire show before the show so I tend to
not do weight training or any kind of
intense physical preparation before a
show because it's about the show I try
to save as much energy for the
performance the fourth thing is recovery
time and this is something that I've
been implementing as I get older and as
my body you know starts to change that
recovery time becomes more crucial so I
started dancing around age 10 and around
the age of 13 or 14 I started to develop
a severe stutter and for about a year
and a half I was intensive speech
therapy to regain my ability to speak
because I couldn't talk dance became a
way for me to communicate and to get out
all the frustrations and all the
feelings that I had inside that I
couldn't get out and around the age of
18
we know when you're in high school and
you're trying to decide what you want to
do next I thought I want to go to
college I want to get a degree in dance
I was accepted to the University of the
Arts in Philadelphia on a full-ride
scholarship I started to develop shin
splints pretty close to when I started
taking ballet classes because
improper technique and I as a dancer
just push through the pain was like I'm
gonna be fine I'm gonna persevere and
overcome all obstacles and it'll be
great the shin splints kept getting
worse and they ended up developing
stress fractures in both shins the
combination of the stress fractures and
being on my feet you know 80 hours a
week and not really making a lot of
money at the time was really hard on me
emotionally and to the point that I
burned out I quit I was done I was gonna
go back to school but while I was at
Columbia I started to get this itch to
dance again I used to beat a lot of
dance history dance Theory dance
criticism and I was reminded of how much
I love the dance field and the industry
and especially its history and I think
that passion that understanding for the
history of dance really kind of
rekindled the flame to actually have a
dance career and towards the end of my
college career I decided you know what
I'm gonna give it one more shot
I'm gonna see if I can actually make
this happen